africain le mot évoque souvent le
folklore la danse ou le sport c'est
flatteur mais je ne sais rien faire de
tout cela je ne sais pas chanter je ne
sais pas danser
will africains qui doivent forcément
savoir danser je vous arrête tout de
suite vous oubliez je ne sais pas danser
je ne sais pas non plus faire du vélo
je ne sais pas nager et je ne sais pas
conduire un jour mon père m'a dit mon
fils vu sa corpulence tu ne sera rien
faire d'autre dans la vie que lire et
écrire
et il avait raison je ne sait faire
qu'une chose est claire saviez-vous
qu'en afrique subsaharienne 32 millions
d'enfants en âge de fréquenter le
primaire ne sont pas scolarisés hors
mondiale alizé l'éducation l arme la
plus puissante que l'on peut utiliser
pour changer le monde
je suis né au sénégal dans une famille
très modeste
mon père était cheminot ma mère femme au
foyer est analphabète
j'ai eu une chance aimé écrire j'ai
toujours écrit pour rêver pour devenir
pour rêver devenir
j'ai eu la chance d'aimer à prendre pour
me lever et aller plus loin ça a
toujours été ma façon de visiter des
univers différents
deux furent une vie en afrique figé
entre deux conceptions politiques
différentes et caricaturale d'une part
l'afrique c est beau la malaria guerre
civile génocide sida
des fléaux qui sonne comme une fatalité
inarrêtable et de l'autre il y à cette
afrique la croissance classes moyennes
émergentes de jeunesse mobile banking
printemps arabe
lune l afro pessimistes symbole de la
défaite et de refus d'une renaissance
africaine l'autre et l'afro optimisme un
discours d'auto persuasion
une manière stérile de se rassurer une
utopie une belle et charmante utopie
alors vous imaginez l'embarras pour moi
christine mustapha nicolas awa et tous
ces jeunes en afrique qui doivent
choisir entre ces deux modèles là mais
nous avons imaginé une voie médiane
l'afro responsabilité nous sommes partis
d'un diagnostic complet de l'afrique
c'est 54 pays un milliard d'habitants la
population la plus jeune au monde 200
millions d'africains sont âgés entre 15
et 24 ans vous savez quoi en 2050 un
quart de la population mondiale sera
africaine
mais dans ce diagnostic nous n'avons
rien occulté ni le génocide au rwanda ni
le coup d'état beaucoup trop l'oms ni
les chiffres alarmants sur la pauvreté
la santé
nous n'avons pas non plus occulter
toutes ces personnes qui désespèrent de
l'afrique et partent chercher vie et
leur connaissance ailleurs quelle est la
valeur des sacrifices consentis par
toutes ces personnes mortes dans l'océan
à l'assaut de lampedusa pourquoi ces
jeunes décide-t-il de quitter leur pays
à tout prix là faut responsabiliser ses
montres et des succès chez nous qu'ils
peuvent consulter des modèles façonner
une nouvelle fois à l'afrique ait quitté
le mythe de l'eldorado européen
la jeunesse africaine est consciente de
son rôle de transformation sociale et de
libération du continent
oui nous avons vécu l'esclavagé oui nous
avons souffert de la colonisation mais
nous avons refusé de nous enfermer dans
ce passé mais au contraire
de l'assimiler et de nous tourner vers
l'avenir
voilà pourquoi nous avons choisi l'afro
responsabilité ce n'est pas seulement un
concept une idée mais un cadre d'action
concrète qui accompagne la dynamique du
continent
ce n'est pas non plus la sphère d'une
élite intellectuelle
mais chacun quel que soit son niveau ou
son diplôme à quelque chose à 10 et à
apporter aujourd'hui les choses bougent
dans l'afrique des économies structure
avec notamment 5 % de croissance en
moyenne sur les dix dernières années et
vous savez sur les dix pays qui ont la
plus forte croissance en 2015
six sont en afrique croissance la france
ça fait rêver non
des frontières disparaissent
progressivement les pays qui ont jadis
connu un passé des dictatures sont
maintenant dans une démocratie
avantageuse et qui marche
mais le plus important c'est la prise de
conscience par la jeunesse africaine de
son rôle pour changer les choses
cette jeunesse dont je fais partie a
décidé de s'impliquer dans les affaires
publiques
elle a décidé de promouvoir les secours
nouveau sur le continent elle a envie de
prendre toute sa place dans le processus
d'émergence du contenu est aujourd'hui
plusieurs axes sont là pour le faire
sortir l'afrique de la pauvreté de masse
et faire en sorte que l'émergence
économique de nos pays devienne une
réalité
la coopération économique au niveau des
états et déjà une belle idée à l'oeuvre
les pays africains à diversifier leur
partenariat et s'orientent vers les pays
émergents comme le brésil l'inde
l'entrepreneur est aussi un réel moteur
de croissance avec une jeunesse
inventive et ingénieuse par exemple le
cetic de dacca et le premier incubateur
de start up dans le domaine des pays
c'est en afrique subsaharienne
francophone avec une soixantaine nombre
d'entreprises créées en trois ans au
burkina faso une start-up développement
savons anti paludisme pour lutter contre
le fléau au nigeria le boom de
l'industrie culturelle promet empruntant
l'économie créative dans le pays et je
vous annonce qu'à dakar vient d'être
labellisé en descend
2014 par l'unesco comme ville créative
voilà c'est tout ça l'afrique actuelle
je suis responsable je le fais depuis
mes études en france
c'est ici pour la première fois que j'ai
entendu parler du mot à vos
responsabilités
révélation déclic j'ai trouvé là un écho
à ma passion pour l'afrique
je voulais parler débattre écrire
discutée elle sortir toute cette envie
l'afrique en moi alors j'ai pris tout de
suite le train en marche
pour participer à la construction de ce
mouvement et le think tank que nous
avons créés en 2011
l'afrique des idées compte aujourd'hui
plus d'une centaine de membres actifs
nous avons des bureaux à paris dakar
lomé cotonou et bientôt à abidjan
nous avons publié plus de 1600 articles
en ligne et nous venons de présenter aux
nations unies un nouvel indicateur de
mesure la place à 5 luz yves en afrique
mais mon affreux responsabilité vécu ici
à des milliers de kilomètres de chez moi
était peu courageuse confortable après
deux nouveaux diplômes en poche et des
opportunités professionnelles en france
une manne new york j'ai décidé de
retourner chez moi il faut que la
jeunesse africaine participe au
processus de construction du continent
alors je rentre et j'entends ma carrière
dans les cabinets ministériels de mon
pays d'abord au ministère des affaires
étrangères puis celui de la culture met
tout de suite les bureaux de
l'administration m'ont dérangé
je ne mets pas ce confort cette absence
de prise de risque et surtout ce
sentiment d'éloignement des réalités de
mon pays alors je quitte à nouveau ces
terrains du confort je décide de
démissionner de la fonction publique
pour me libérer les quarts contre la
bureaucratie
voilà après les na li sénégal l'ena en
france et le celsa
je viens de quitter la haute fonction
publique avec un emploi et un salaire
garanti à vie pour aller à la rencontre
des africains et comprendre leur
perception de la marche du continent
alors je voyage je prends le bus
je vais au mali à bamako je rencontre
madame aminata traoré ancien ministre de
la culture et icône de
l'altermondialisme elle m'a parlé de son
drame de voir les maliens s'entretuer
alors qu'ils auraient pu construire leur
pays
elle m'a parlé aussi de sa souffrance de
mer à chaque fois qu'elle voyage et
qu'elle croise des jeunes réduits à la
misère en occident au mali toujours mais
accueille cette fois j'ai eu une
discussion inoubliable avec deux
sénégalais qui rentrait en bus après les
années l'immigration ils me parlaient de
leur déception de le régler et surtout
le sentiment de gâchis qui les anime et
il aurait pu consacrer l'énergie de la
survie quotidienne du clandestin à la
construction d'un mieux-être au sénégal
je quitte le manu je pars en mauritanie
je croise deux jeunes engagés dans la
lutte contre l'exclusion
ils sont victimes de racisme dans leur
propre pays mais j'ai aussi rencontré
d'autres personnes extraordinaires et
des histoires fabuleuses omar victor
diop a quitté une carrière dans une
multinationale pour se consacrer à sa
passion la photo aujourd'hui circule
dans le monde pour montrer les clichés
de l'afrique dynamique et émergentes
victoria a quitté une banque
internationale en europe pour fonder le
premier cabinet de conseil en afrique
subsaharienne francophone
thierry bouffe liberia vient d'inventer
la première tablette 100% africaine tous
ces voyages étaient passionnantes
toutes ces rencontres énorme aujourd'hui
je bouillonne j'ai soif de concret j'ai
envie d'accompagner cette dynamisme de
la jeunesse africaine
l'afro responsabilité c'est une jeunesse
qui se parlent qu'ils se donnent la main
et passe en commun sont l'avenir c'est
une jeunesse qui se libèrent l'héritage
de ses aînés pour inaugurer un modèle
nouveau né pour être actrice de son
destin j'ai fait partie d'une génération
pour qu'il vienne à un possible si nous
sommes conscients de notre rôle de
moteur du changement en afrique avec
créativité
agilité et passion nous pouvons
construire une afrique nouvelle fois
d'égalité de justice et de progrès ce
que je fais actuellement 100% entre le
responsable prendre mon destin en main
regardez l'afrique autrement venir vous
en parlait ici ce soir avant de terminer
je voudrais vous demander quelque chose
ne regardez plus l'afrique seulement à
travers la télévision n'ai plus peur de
l'afrique
venez voir et jauger le potentiel qui
existe mais soyez conscient que ma
génération c'est la seule maîtresse de
son destin
sahel elle scelle qu'incombe le fait de
devenir le moteur du changement en
afrique
nous voulons prendre le pouvoir et
construire
l'émergence du nouveau rêve africain
c'est un drôle de coup d'état qui se
prépare un coup d'état afro responsable